These have just been some of the methods that we
can use when performing statistical tests on data. As you
can imagine, there are a number of additional ways to
handle data from different probability distributions or data that looks
like it came from no probability distribution whatsoever. Data scientists
can perform many statistical procedures. But it's vital to understand
the underlying structure of the data set and consequently, which
statistical tests are appropriate given the data that we have.
There are many different types of statistical tests and even many
different schools of thought within statistics
regarding the correct way to analyze
data. This has really just been an opportunity to get your
feet wet with statistical analysis. It's just the tip of the iceberg.